bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 ans ceci
à novembre après les élections
américaines nous nous intéressons ce
soir aux élections pour la présidence de
l'ump en france aurore bergé militant
auprès de la fédération des yvelines
sera l'invité politique du jour aux
alentours de 18h30
si vous nous suivez en direct sur télé
fils elle nous dira aussi si elle compte
se présenter dans les prochains mois à
la présidence des jeunes populaires à la
branche des jeunes ump
et puis si elle brigue également le
poste de maire à magny les hameaux
élections en 2014 pour le moment sur ce
plateau
jean-claude guennec bonsoir à vous
souffrez vous êtes le président de
l'union des producteurs de fruits et
légumes d'île de france
aujourd'hui l'assemblée nationale a voté
le budget de l'agriculture plusieurs
mesures de prise vous nous direz si ces
mesures vous satisfont ou pas mais déjà
un mot sur ce budget en diminution les
crédits pour le ministère de
l'agriculture et qui va passer de 3,47
milliards à 3,1 milliards pour 2013
votre avis sur cette diminution de
budget ce que c'est un mauvais signe un
coup dur pour l'agriculture en france
c'est un coup dur pour l'agriculture en
france ceci représentera une 10% et je
crois que c'est une somme relativement
importante surtout au niveau de l'aide
de l'agriculture les années qu'on
passait en fonction des productions
situations peuvent être différentes au
niveau des séries mtv différent mais
c'est vrai que l'ambiance générale de
l'agriculture est extrêmement complexe
du fait des conditions climatiques
sécheresses ou trop d'eau ou trop de gel
budget de crise mais déjà difficile pour
ce ministère de l'agriculture vous allez
revenir avec nous sur les différents
détails différentes mesures qui ont été
votées cet après-midi valérie auribeau
bonsoir pour la rédaction de tv shield
en une quinzaine de minutes nous allons
passer à la chronique de l'environnement
et ce soir nous parlerons champignons
cette saison absolument cette saison est
donc un mycologue un spécialiste sera
avec nous un expert de l'association des
naturalistes des yvelines
sur ce plateau tout alors pu nous parler
champignons avec un peu de chance il
nous donnera des bons coins où dénicher
les champignons c'est qu'ils sont en
général qu'ils gardent leurs
informations verra si on va réussir à ou
non à le convaincre à nous donner ses
bons plans à la chronique environnement
ce sera dans une quinzaine de minutes
pour l'instant nous passons au titre les
sujets que nous allons retrouver au
cours de cette édition les titres en
images
la compétitivité louis gallois vient de
remettre son rapport au gouvernement
nous avons recueilli l'avis de chefs
d'entreprise saint quentinois vous les
entendrez tout à l'heure une pétition
pour dire non à la production
d'agrocarburants industriels
l'initiative d'artisans du monde cela
s'est déroulé à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
si vous aimez les champignons et vous ne
savez pas comment les choisir et où les
cueillir l'association des naturalistes
des yvelines organise des balades
commentées reportages et puis nous vous
le disions aussi invité sur ce plateau
tout à l'heure enfin trois musiciens de
formation propose en ce moment à la
verrière un conte musical la malle aux
sortilèges un voyage à la découverte
d'instruments du monde entier on passe
pour l'instant à ce fait du jour et
cette baisse des budgets des crédits
pour l'agriculture en france
jean claude guénin qui nous accompagne
donc pour cette première partie du 7-8
ce soit en ce 6 novembre président de
l'union des producteurs de fruits et
légumes d'île de france
un maraîcher également au mesnil-le-roi
on va regarder un chiffre le chiffre de
cette édition pour débuter 3% 3% le
chiffre qui va paraître c'est la baisse
annoncée du budget du ministère de
l'agriculture si l'on intègre le report
de fond de l'an dernier puis les
subventions aussi à l'enseignement
agricole sa fait environ 3% 10 ans si on
exclut le report de l'an dernier et puis
les subventions donc à l'enseignement
agricole pour être très précis jeunes
agriculteurs et fédération nationale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles
dénoncent un budget de crise alors
qu'ils attendaient plutôt un budget
d'anti crise c'est ce que vous attendiez
aussi vous auriez voulu un budget des
mesures prises pour relancer le secteur
alors aujourd'hui le secteur ce qui nous
importe aujourd'hui c'est sur le crédit
du ministre de l'agriculture l'ensemble
de l'agriculture dont un secteur qui
concerne principalement la manoeuvre ou
là est en discussions aujourd'hui sur
les charges étaient par ailleurs
saisonnier donc le budget est rogné sur
les ruptures mais ni automatiquement au
niveau d'un et charge nos saisonniers
je sais commandement été votée cet après
midi donc c'est la suppression des
charges sociales pour nos saisonniers
assez loin près de lumbres à qui ça
c'est le point précis le plus sain mais
celestina s'arrêter sur ce point
justement alors pour une autre séquence
et l'exonération de charges pas trop
et qui était possible pour les emplois
des travailleurs occasionnels et des
demandeurs d'emploi en d'autres termes
les saisonniers mais c'est vous les avez
mentionné donc maintenant il n'y aura
plus d'exonération en tout cas ce sera
plus difficile de les obtenir
et ça ça va pénaliser votre secteur pour
l'instant c'est supprimer
je sais que le mini c'est le premier
ministre alors à l'assemblée nationale
cet après midi sont intervenus il y aura
peut-être des aménagements mais il est
clair qu'aujourd'hui pour une entreprise
je dirais du secteur spécialisé où on
emploie énormément de main d'oeuvre pour
nous pour l'exploitation type ça peut
nous coûter jeu par exploitation aux
alentours de 30 à 35 mille euros donc
ira peut-être d'autres choses mais pour
l'instant c'est un peu ça va coûter
beaucoup plus cher pour employer
maintenant la main d'oeuvre lorsque vous
en avez besoin ponctuellement pour des
récoltes par exemple mais là c'était
justement pour les récoltes travail
saigner pour récolter les fruits en
saison d'envoyer des jeunes ou des s'est
donné un petit peu plus j'irai deux mois
trois mois ou quatre mois et donc la
plus d'exonérations de charges tel que
c'était prévu par la loi
et c'était depuis une trentaine d'années
mis systématiquement en place étaient
prorogées et on a eu des rallonges
supplémentaires justement pour pouvoir
bénéficier pour la bonne et simple
raison c'est pour être compétitif par
rapport à nos pays voisins
je cite simplement l'allemagne où est il
en panne la manade assise au delà vous
me dire comment ils font dans l'europe
il utilise des contrats saisonniers de
pays vraiment de l'est à des tarifs
défiant toute concurrence donc nous a
pas charger galles on est prêt mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas lutter
combien coûte aujourd'hui l'emploi d'un
an travailleurs saisonniers dans une
exploitation aujourd'hui c'est aux
alentours de 10 ou 11 ans travailleur
saisonnier 10 au 11 10 10 euros à 10
euros 10 euros
et après au niveau permanence et aux
alentours de 13h ou 13 à 14 euros et
donc la secousse passerait à combien
maintenant avec 700 balazans
d'exonération ça va revenir pour un
employeur combien d'emplois comme
combien plan un employeur aujourd'hui
s'il n'ya plus d'exonération sa part
minimum par salarié par mois 500 euros
qu'on estimait brouette de la région est
longue de manque à gagner
ap donc sur vos différents une charge
supplémentaire et quelles conséquences
ça peut avoir sur le long terme la
disparition de ces professions tout
simplement alors
un exemple qui est très simple c'est au
niveau des vergers de l'agriculture
francilienne dans les yvelines il reste
encore un peu de vergers mais
aujourd'hui vu les conditions
climatiques qu'ils ont eue c'est là ils
ont des calamités dramatique le gel ou
l'année prochaine
ils ne pourront pas supporter cette
augmentation de charge
c'est impossible donc les récoltes
resteront peut-être dans les vergers où
les gens arrêteront purement et
simplement au sort justement des
différentes professions d'entreprise que
vous pouvez représenter il ya des
inquiétudes fortes qui se sont
manifestés ya eu des mobilisations des
manifestations d ir déjà désignèrent
savait déjà depuis un certain temps déjà
depuis le diaboliquement personnellement
j'ai écrit à tous les députés et
sénateurs
c'est eux qui votent les lois de les
alerter sur la situation de l'île de
france
et hier nous avons été à l'assemblée
nationale manifester justement en
apportant j'irai nos derniers fruits
nos derniers légumes nos dernières
fleurs parce que nous sommes très très
très inquiet ça veut dire sinon si on
poursuit la logique on peut s'attendre
pour le consommateur une hausse des
coûts si vous continuez vos activités
vous allez forcément répercuté s'assure
décrit sur les coûts sur les ventes
aujourd'hui c'est impossible de
récupérer donc hyper s'utilise sur les
coûts c'est la loi de l'offre et de la
demande
donc les coûts varient selon les pays
étrangers ce ne sera pas possible donc
c'est très simple si je prends la salade
ou l'île de fond le des yvelines est un
gros producteur de salade notamment à
remonter son est bien les salades qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire
ils vont pas partir de montesson pour
les régimes où elle est dans les
magasins de la région
ils vont venir directement d'allemagne
sur les plateformes et les 18 heures ils
vont prendre part des consommateurs
même si le pays est un petit peu plus
cher un produit il ya un tel
différentiel qui ne pourront pas
continuer à acheter nos produits y
laisseront au moins cher et donc des
produits allemands pourront venir
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui pour
l'aspergent et la fraise vous nous
disiez être mobilisés avoir écrit aux
députés aux sénateurs vous être
également mobilisés
hier est ce que vous avez le sentiment
en tout cas d'avoir été un peu entendu
il ya eu cette avancée en fin de journée
avec le gouvernement qui a évoqué ouvert
la porte de d'aménagement sur ces
suppressions d'exonérations de charges
je pense un peu comme un fruit juste
alors si ça va porter ses fruits mais
c'est très très long bon je doute un
petit peu aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ne connaissent
pas bien l'agriculture
ça nous d'essayer les nouveaux élus de
la majorité actuelle c'est à nous de les
emmener sur le terrain de leur faire
comprendre qu'on est un secteur un petit
peu différent des autres
nous on veut partir de banque qu'on est
à concurrence égales avec nos pays
voisins on peut supporter les charges
mais aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
et donc on délocalise même contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser c'est pas nos
entreprises qui vont être délocalisés
c'est le produit qui va se délocaliser
il ya un lobbying intense qui s'engagent
à bas toute façon on est parti pour le
lobbying et on va pas lâcher la faire on
va continuer on va aller jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est l'avenir de nos
entreprises et l'avenir aussi de la
consommation dit manger français mangent
et régionaux et aujourd'hui si je prends
un produit la fraise la framboise et il
s'en fait énormément dans les yvelines
et via ces gens là ne seront plus du
tout compétitifs et donc ça sera plus
possible de produire ces produits là
qu'est ce qu'on fera mieux en tant que
chef d'entreprise et bien on arrêtera
ses cultures et ils disparaîtront et on
verra sur l'autoroute comme là on le
voit sur le tour de l'ouest les vergers
de chambourcy aujourd'hui il ya
pratiquement plus un verger à chambourcy
et c'était berceau de la foire de la
pomme et aujourd'hui il ya des maisons
où il ya des friches et c'est ça qui
risque d'arriver dans quelques années et
rapidement ce à très court terme aux
imaginales cette série vation je dirais
dans les deux années et où des trois
années qui viennent
c'est si on nous met les chats on
demande des allègements de charge depuis
plusieurs années il faut continuer dans
ce sens là pour pouvoir exercer et
apporter aux consommateurs
nos produits régionaux juste une
dernière question tout de même on parle
de budget de crise de situations
difficiles en france mais pas seulement
en europe également vous répondez quoi
lorsqu'on vous explique que c'est parce
qu'il ya une crise qu'il faut bien faire
des économies quelque part vous dites
oui faisons des économies mais pas chez
nous dans mes doudous nous les économies
on les a déjà fait comme on est sur un
marché où l'on maîtrise pas du tout les
cours si on gagne arrivé à augmenter nos
prix soit sur une tête de salade
5 6 centimes ça nous suffit on ne manque
pas je dirais des sommes énormes on
n'ait pas contribué
mais nous est compté le but c'est de
contribuer je dirais en se battant pour
une diminution d'achat en plus seulement
pour embaucher des gens pour éviter
d'avoir du chômage est justement de
contribuer au redressement de la france
nous c'est dans ce schéma là qu'on les
parties merci donc pour ces réactions je
propose de rester encore quelques
instants je rappelais déjà budget en
baisse pour les agriculteurs et puis ces
inquiétudes que vous avez exprimé je
vous propose de rester juste quelques
instants nous allons ouvrir une page
environnement avec un reportage qui va
forcément vous intéresser